My grandson two and a half years old keeps getting sick first draft and two weeks later another infection and bad cough then two weeks later now fever again, he had two rounds of antibiotics, what can he do?
Okay, so so the thing is is that when our children get ill, we live in a culture where we tend to run them to the doctor and get it antibiotic.
So sometimes when you got a nasty strapped infection, you should get it antibiotic. You don't want it to bleed to something worse like pandas or something.
But most of the time, if you let that child cycle through that infection, so when you first get an infection, you have this immediate response.
That's your immediate immediate response. That's called a TH1 response with all these different types of immediate immune cytokine releases and chemokine releases that are attacking the infection.
So they give it is that this infection, these bad guys that entered the body and this immediate response is the police force that's going out to try to kill this infection.
Well, if it's a pretty nasty infection, the police force can't kill it. And after a few days, the police force gets called back and they said the FBI and the FBI get in there.
That's your B cell or TH2 response to go in there and find the enemies and take them with fluorescent tape so that now the police can see them and find them easier.
That's called a TH1 TH2 full immune response, which is hindered if we run off and get antibiotics or first my kids got a fever, so I'm going to take tile it all.
Then we're not letting them cycle through this whole TH1 TH2 response. And only when you go through that TH2 B cell response, will you create antibodies against that infection?
Now, the benefit of creating antibodies against an infection is that after the infection is over, you still have circulated antibodies against that infection.
That's what you say. Oh, Johnny's got such a strong immune system, he doesn't get sick. Well, why doesn't Johnny get sick? He's still exposed to everything that Billy's exposed to, but Billy keeps getting sick.
Well, Johnny's mom let him cycle through that whole infectious process at least a few times. So now he's got circulated antibodies against that strep.
So what he's exposed to the same amount of strep that Billy's exposed to, Billy doesn't have circulated antibodies. He gets sick.
Johnny doesn't get really sick. Maybe he has a feel great for a day or so, but the antibodies take the strep than the TH1 police force get in there and kill the strep.
That's what's called haven't in a healthy immune system. So the definition of a healthy immune system is means that I am more circulated antibodies against more pathogens than somebody else does.
So I have a healthier immune system than somebody else because I have more circulated antibodies against more pathogens. That's what you want to have.
That's the only way that you can have that is if you allow yourself to get sick and you nurse yourself through that sickness and have some chicken soup and take some supplements and build up your immune system and strengthen your immune system so that you do fire a whole B cell response and develop antibodies for that.
But I know we live in the most generation. We've lived in a culture where you know mom's not home. We can't stay home. We got to run to the doctor, get an antibiotic otherwise they won't let it back into take care or school or whatever.
And that's not necessarily good. And so we need to develop that immune system.
Other things help build up for child's immune system to where they breastfed you know what's the what's the child's diet like are they eat a lot of different food so they have a good healthy probiotic sources to help build their microbiota.
Are they supporting their immune system through different nutrition? Are they eating dyes and food colorings or are they eating in the inflammatory diet or are they eating things that they have antibodies against are they eating glue to the dairy and things that they might have antibodies.
And that are causing inflammation and they're fighting this battle at both ends and now they got this inflammatory process right off this infection. So you want to take a big picture approach that and dig into this whether they're five years old or whether you're 25 years old.